all right today family feud
[Laughter]
can we pull it up on the screen
um pull what up on the screen oh the
multiple questions
but it looks really good as a visual on
the post so we can you know but that's
what he does after yeah okay cool yeah i
know that and yeah shout out to you jp
because that looks really good it looked
awesome man it looked really good on
video that uh yeah yo do you guys notice
jp's new threats he's using that editor
money coming in looking fresh he got a
leather jacket i'm pretty sure
okay yeah he's you okay
i don't know
i don't know
the glasses look like a new frame don't
even worry about him
don't even worry about gp he's you he's
if he got the money like he's you better
you bet he's saving up oh yeah
[ __ ] smart don't even worry
about that [ __ ] you don't spend
you don't spend nothing this
[ __ ] hey don't even this
[ __ ] keeps to himself he does
his thing yo don't even worry about that
i see you okay
i see you all right i'm just saying no
front no
he's not gonna the one that's
extravagant and that show [ __ ] that's me
that's already
that's already established we don't need
to invest we don't need to rehash that
but but gp's not going to be the one
that's going to be like yeah fresh new
jacket man thinking stuff everything is
all over i see you gp all right hit us
let's get it popping gp aj
[Music]
all right we're coming back to family
feud yeah let's go family feud that's
right so
it took the reason why it took so long
is because apple was so pissed about it
what you mean last time with the boomers
name ways people usually change their
appearance
plastic surgery
not on the board
they change their hair color
dye their hair is the number one answer
[Laughter]
makeup
makeup
[Laughter]
oh yeah
i'm ready to get triggered again
i need a break in between every time
let's see what these [ __ ] old geezers
thinking yeah
all right let's go what we got i got
them from a different website but
doesn't matter i think someone's going
to be angry at some point
and by someone he's like abba
we know what that someone is all right
let's go
all right man i've been practicing my
steve harvey face so no no it's team
harvey
barbie with steve harvey
all right yeah
so
you know the name of the game
you know the rules the top answers are
on the board yeah so uh
first one to uh tap on that table
is gonna answer cool all right
first category
name things you spend lottery winnings
on car
you know
can i take and appreciate something
i don't even have an answer i just
thought this [ __ ]
he said he just wanted a tab
you're not gonna press that button for
me [ __ ]
[Laughter]
cars is the number four answer cool
after that we're gonna go
house
uh yes number one answer mansions then
uh
we gonna go into
boat
boat is not on the board all right your
turn i just want to say and appreciate
this that ever since he came into his
youtube money he pretty much won the
lottery so
he's just saying what this [ __ ]
purchased personally and i wanna just
say how unfair that is why somebody who
hasn't uh bought anything you know what
i'm saying if i hold
rich people buy boats
is that an answer
i already said vote no boats is not on
already said you have a boat you said
what i just said
was that the last one he said that's the
last one i said he said it's okay you
lost that one goddamn that's very
disappointing yeah
hey man i know you want to vote
[Music]
that's the only thing that came to my
mind
motorcycles
motorcycles is not on the board uh debt
payoff debts is the number three answer
all right good job you got to pay off
debts yeah yeah uh vacation
vacation number two yeah see good job
well i mean i get money i'm going
somewhere yeah so i can spend it what
else we got and there's one i want to
answer left we got two more
um okay so went through that
they already bought a house so i think
at this point
presents
gifts
gifts is not on the board okay clothes
that's stupid
these are fiscally responsible people
investment
i'm gonna give it to you start a company
oh yeah sure yeah is the seventh answer
yeah we got one more
[ __ ]
uh uh one more guess from me um
golf clips
that's not there but you just thought
rich people or golfers
what's the last answer the last one is
education
okay
okay wait so like what they paying for
school yeah i feel like that would fall
into debt no
student debt they're paying to go to
school stop it's not a debt okay it
makes sense
i was really thinking the student debt
when i was saying that
all right all right i've done points
you got the first and the fourth
question we're going to do
quick muffs all right abby's at 46
points and preach is
at 30 40. oh
that first answer must have been a lot
you get
not all answers are created equal
all right after the first round we got
ab ahead by two points 46 preach at 44.
all right
all right next round
top
six answers are on the board
name foods that go with peanut butter
bread
red is not on the board
[Music]
what the [ __ ] do you think nobody said
bread
you'll find the website bro
listen talk to steve harvey bro don't
talk to me
oh my gosh
revenge how does that feel oh bread was
not on that that is crazy that's [ __ ]
up peanut butter jelly time peanut
butter jelly time peanut butter jelly
peanut butter peanut butter with a
baseball bat yeah you know what the tree
is you say it's not on the list you know
why are you laughing that much
it's on the list jelly
it's number one
you know what the thing is
is i'm pretty sure you would have said
bread first no i said jelly oh okay yeah
i literally thought of jelly immediately
so go ahead when you use that bread i'm
like that's a good answer go ahead
uh what goes
jam
is not on the board no really okay
i just want to give you a chance to get
some points yeah sure
what is the difference between jam and
jelly um
listen there's somebody in the comments
who we're going to know i think i'll be
mad at you for saying jam is just like
pureed things and jelly there's pectin
in it so it look there's more of the
consistency that was so technical it's
kind of yeah yeah
i remember reading pectin on the back of
a jelly jar there you go okay all right
all right um
[Music]
uh
yeah i'm gonna go with dumplings which
is not gonna be there
chinese food
something's not on the board go ahead
uh
noodles
yeah
i've seen peanuts go in noodles yeah
you're right
think old and uncultured
yeah this is going to be a tough one
yeah people who've never seen bread
honestly i always ate peanut butter okay
okay i don't know you you dropped it it
wasn't this my turn yeah
chocolate yes chocolate is number two
that's exactly what i was going to say i
thought of nutella
i've definitely done that before when i
was a kid
uh candy
candy is not on the board
oatmeal
oats is the number five answer
the old white people when i was in the
military i got to witness it i didn't
know
yay
you should try it okay no
okay bro i have another one
um
in like a shake milkshake thingy
milkshake is thingy is not on the board
milkshake titty thingy is not no you
know like when they put it in with like
um
no the berries and [ __ ] like that they
said no this [ __ ] okay
i know it goes in drinks so you should
know the drink
huh they put it in drinks all the time
and drinks yeah like cocktails and [ __ ]
not cocktails like that but it's like
juices or some [ __ ] like that
but go ahead
you have another idea i'm going to rum
and coke with peanut butter please
not live two shots four shots of tequila
peanut butter chasers
i'm not gonna lie i can see that
happening yeah yeah
listen considering there's all kinds of
[ __ ] up crazy drinks out there you
don't see peanut butter being used
really fair
okay
just killing a whole bunch of
[ __ ] in your bar right man with
peanut allergies
all right all right hit it
i don't know [ __ ] dude they took bread
away i know
yes they took bread away they guess my
heart is broken effects
um
[ __ ]
no because motherfucker's gonna spread
that butter they're not yeah no we're
not doing that uh no no but yeah no i
don't have that i have nothing i have
bread chicken
chicken is not all right then we're done
all right a few answers you know what i
said chicken
butter chicken
that's not what is
that's not what it means
that's not what butter chicken means
that's not what it means
now you just make it on purpose to piss
[ __ ]
that's not what it means
oh my gosh
oh my days this [ __ ] went butter
chicken
i thought i was just staring at you i
saw your face i was like this shit's
stupid
this shit's stupid look at this face
this is stupid and guess what
it was
hey you know what it was dumber what not
having bread yeah
that was stupid thank you okay
go ahead i didn't bat an eyelash because
i've had straight up chicken with peanut
butter and it's pretty dope yeah i feel
like that's a thing somewhere in america
100
you're looking at me like steve harvey
dawg i'm dead serious there's 100
people who eat chicken with peanut
butter i'm pretty sure
i actually want to try peanut sauce
i used to and that's when that's the
exact time actually the peak of my weed
smoke
it really sounds like
munchies
i know what we gonna do what
chicken and peanut butter
because i had chicken right and then i
always loved peanut sauce bro
what are you saying okay
you know what happened i had chicken
right
wrong
it doesn't make it right dude don't
knock it till you try it that's all i'm
saying all right all right hit us all
right so the number four answer was
oreos
this is america i will slap a
[ __ ] as well yeah that's nasty
and the last one may be nastier celery
i'm not mad i i've heard i've heard
people do that with certain pregnant
women yeah i've seen it on commercials
yeah they took like
a couple of pregnant women and it was
like yeah that's just delicious
because you got the crunchiness of the
salary
the smoothness of the peanut butter
i like that i like that yeah all right
all right hit us with the next category
all right the next round top four
answers are on the board name a
fictional fantasy book series with a
large fan base
harry potter harry potter
lord of the rings
lord of the rings number two
and then number three
i don't know some [ __ ] superhero
movie like spider-man
spider-man is not on the board what's
the question
name a fictional fantasy book series
with a large fan base
there's no books for spider-man but um
50 shades of grey
for my woman's out there that little
celery is that is that is that there no
it's not it's not face fictional fantasy
book series
fantasy
uh game of thrones
game of thrones is on the board yeah
this is my nerd [ __ ] pretty much yeah
you said game of thrones lord of the
rings harry potter yeah
um
those are the star wars
star wars is not on the board books
yeah they have books do they i don't
think they're known for the books they
don't have the movies i don't care they
have books
um i can't think of another one what's
the answer
the
hunger games
twilight
[Music]
we got nine points to jp nine points
yeah
take me grab his glasses like an anime
character said twilight
[Laughter]
all right now [ __ ] are gonna
have to have a camera on gp
yeah yeah yeah i want to see him let's
see who this rich editor is i'm looking
for a baby daddy
you already got a girl
i got a girl he's my best friend
that's cute
i'm tallying up the points here
i gotta be no you ate that one you what
yeah i mean that was that was that was
my no you ate that
like i don't even
watch harry potter one and i knew it was
harry potter just do something like
uh top 10 rifles or
top five uh
cycles or
best cars you know what i mean like i
mean i think i could compete with cars
no you can't i can't no you can't
bruh yo you are we rolling down the
street and you're like yo what's that
like uh i don't gotta know what they
look like i just gotta say the name that
i heard before honda prius really yeah
yeah is that a subaru corolla
is he coming up with some wild [ __ ] bro
just to piss the [ __ ] off i'm a
big fan of the honda chargers
what's my favorite team bro
ah you can't say that to an american
what the [ __ ] did you say hey man this
america this is america and the country
boy is good enough for me all right
okay now
i'm gonna try to do my best steve harvey
voice
top four answers are on the board
that was dr phil [ __ ]
hello
[Music]
you just went deeper and southerner now
i heard that [ __ ] i'm like django
unchained
that's exactly what i thought
all right hit us i think that was dr
phil i think dr phil is white steve
harvey a little bit yeah absolutely
because you have to take in
concentration
but there's a way that
so you never talk to yourself once in
your life that maybe
top four answers are on the board name a
dish or ingredient you might find on the
menu at an expensive restaurant
preach
oysters
bruh
broke ass [ __ ] that's what it
is
go ahead
uh what's the little circle things that
they put on everything that we're not
going to say you find it
you pepperoni i know what it is but you
find it figure it out caviar caviar is
the number one answer good job
yeah
yeah caviar's got to be number one uh
i don't even know this is but it sounds
kind of cool
um
calamari
calamari is not on the board you could
get that [ __ ] at casual spa yeah yeah
yeah
i don't think this is it but it sounds
kind of cool lobster
lobster is number two oh okay i don't
think it would be
steak steak is number three
wait is this dishes
or ingredients ingredient dish or
ingredient okay
so we got three of them i've got one i
got an answer got one left i'll go ahead
go ahead
saffron
i like it but no no that's too too much
you went too specific though but the
ingredients yeah yeah yeah
yeah you went too rich i remember
watching a youtube documentary about
saffron yeah it's crazy that's too
ethnic for this group yeah yeah
saffron
you want to go for the last one um
yeah we don't got it
the final one very trendy right now
truffles oh actually that yeah
yeah more than the frog because i'd be
hearing i'll be hearing that [ __ ] all
the time
so let me tally up the points real quick
we got abba at an overall of 236 after
four rounds and preach 167 130.
preach at 123. okay
i gave you more 167. i was being
generous
you [ __ ] ate the last two ones like
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean yeah i think
getting the uh that game of thrones and
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
but also caviar caviar is just like
everywhere i've seen a little bubble i
think they're okay i don't think they're
that great the eye i don't think they're
that great they make fake caviar now
yeah honestly i kind of cringe because
sometimes i'll be watching these
five-star restaurants on youtube and
like seeing like everything is just
caviar and you know what it is it's just
like you all use the same ingredients
that's just boring you know what caviar
is though
i don't know they grow it on farms don't
they no it's fish eggs don't they i'm
pretty sure i see like aquatic farms
fish fish farms yeah i'm sure they're
farmers in france i see them do them
little canes and [ __ ] fish eggs yeah
yeah they just
jerk a fish out oh really yeah
that should come out
oh what do you do for work i jerk off
fish
all right next question
you're not comfortable with it
so it's just like fart jokes with you
are weird
all right
top
five answers are on the board
name red flags on a dating site
dessert no job
you got not on the board
uh
a red flag that i think some people
probably see all the pictures are with
somebody else
that's right that is the number five
answers all group photos yeah that's 100
a huge red flag
um
i think there's probably like women who
are answering a lot they'll probably say
no profile
no photo that's right his number one
answer yeah
um
i'm gonna say
too attractive
too attractive is definitely not on the
board
catfish i assume you did this yeah yeah
sometimes when someone's too hot
especially for men men see a really hot
girl sometimes they don't think it's
real because it's like a bot no no you
messing yeah no oh you gotta keep it
i don't know
when they say no no chinese and no
blacks
racial preferences is that not the port
no that's totally cool in america i
think
to be fair hinge has a racial component
you can literally choose what races
filter out hinge yeah so you don't have
to you don't have to put it out there
that you're racist right yeah because
honestly like it's just between you and
the app
okay
to be fair to be fair sometimes you're
in the city and all you see are just
like white women you know sometimes you
want to just switch it up a little bit
not always because like some dating apps
are just dominated by white women just
don't hate in seattle
i've used that toggle before
i'm gonna say like um a red flag would
probably be
um all like the same angle
uh not on the board no body
we just say face we don't see body yeah
i want to see body
this is on the profile on a dating site
or profile red flags on a dating site
assuming when you look at their profile
what stands out as a red flag okay
i don't know look at those uh pictures
with the opposite six
not there i don't know i don't i don't
watch those [ __ ] this well what you
steve harvey bro steve harvey wrote all
this there because it's unfair so what
what what are the events all right
the second answer is creepy messages
but see that's not on the profile
i just want to ask
doesn't matter that's that's not him
okay well yeah next
uh i don't understand the third one at
all it just says venmo slash cash app
slash zell oh whenever girls ask for
cash yeah so basically some women who
are just there to like get money from
people
they just put it up right there yeah
that's why i was saying the too hot
thing because well generally women are
too attractive that's what they're there
for
so we're supposed to look at your
profile and be like here's 20 bucks yes
simply sam i can't date you but here's a
little cash yeah well how do you think
only fans work
yeah but you could at least you know
browse some photos
you think that most of the women are
only things who get money are not even
getting it from the subscriptions
they're getting it from people in the
dms who just send the money and they
have somebody else reply for them so
just like the personal interaction do
you get money from that
it's not from the content what a world
yeah yeah so for example daniel bergoli
the
girl who catch me outside catch me
outside she made 50 million dollars in
one year from only fans vast majority it
wasn't from like nudes or porn the vast
majority was like conversation with
people she hired to reply to people of
course so that's just something to think
about
they should the cash app should use her
as like a spokesperson
outside cash me outside so you can catch
me inside this wallet yeah yeah cash at
me outside
uh
and the number four answer is when
somebody writes no drama in their
profile yeah
those are not really the biggest ones
don't don't calculate that let me tell
you something let me tell you something
women will oftentimes not reply to a
dude or not swipe brown dude if he's
taking pictures with a bunch of women
that 100
in the comments let us know how much of
it is a red flag if you see a guy as a
woman and they only have pictures of the
girls or if you see a girl she only has
pictures with dudes yeah that's a red
flag
you know what i'm saying that'll be like
something
that like people will be completely
turned up why would you do that yeah
also another one that's a red flag some
people who put like their astrology in
their profile mm-hmm
big red flag
[ __ ] like that'd be crazy sapiosexual
red flags
big big red flag
all right you wanna hit us with the next
one uh yes sir
all right are you calculating that round
i'm calculating so hey listen another
plus 100 for apple we just move on yeah
pretty much i'm out of it
yeah we could see a big comeback who
knows no we can't believe in yourself
stop
let's go
all right
top five answers are on the board name a
play
by shakespeare
yes sir otello
othello's not on the board
you know what's the worst part is that's
my favorite playboy doesn't matter it's
not there
not theirs go ahead not even top five
the top one is going to be romeo juliet
yeah absolutely number one answer romeo
juliet
that was that's an obvious one but
othello was the one that you know as a
black man i felt some type of way we
read that in 10th grade i know it's a
good one
uh what else does shakespeare do
those are the only two i know
othello and romeo and juliet no matter
what i'm going to name the next it's not
going to be there
well listen i i listen man in the iron
mask
even gp went what
all right
i just wanna i wanna
i wanna apologize to alexander zuma are
you my favorite author okay i know it's
not that's all i could do even jp
what
that was one of his later works all
right so go for it king lear
king lear is not on the board go ahead
uh
king arthur
[Laughter]
all right
hey man all right i'm just taking stabs
in the dark i'm not even going to french
macbeth spider-man big bass oh that's
got to be there macbeth is on the board
number
is it number two right macbeth is the
number three answer who was number two i
don't know what number two is
all right just keep guessing bro because
i'm gonna just say dumb [ __ ] you [ __ ]
don't say it so yeah
bro listen i'ma just name medieval
[ __ ] that's all i'm gonna do
i don't know uh napoleon
that's really the only word that's good
in my mind
start naming game of thrones characters
yeah
daenerys go all right what's your name i
don't remember his place so
that's it that's all i got
hamlet is a number two answer thanks i'm
thrilled
get off google bro
this [ __ ] guy keeps pushing up his
clash like he's an anime feeling like
like he's not typing all cool
get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah yeah we know what you're doing back
there
cheater
uh number two is hamlet
jp you want to go for number i'm not
going front i'm not going for othello
not being in there is offensive yeah it
is yeah that's how you know it's all the
white boomers
yeah [ __ ] boomer i know of it but uh
i won't say it
all right i've heard that's the play
that must not be named um
number four is a midsummer night's dream
nobody gives a [ __ ] about that ain't
nobody gives a
ain't
god
give a [ __ ] about that yeah you said
that [ __ ] he said a midnight summer and
jp like ah [ __ ] man
jamie went oh man oh yeah
that was my [ __ ] in middle school you
know me and my girl yeah but this
[ __ ] just graduated
no
jb does this and then just kind of
smarter every two seconds yeah
all right let's hear this one
and the last one is julius caesar
see yo i'm just that that's even a play
by him because i thought julian was just
a real [ __ ] who did some [ __ ] okay he
is okay you had to memorize that in high
school julius caesar yeah we had a
[ __ ] intense teacher from trinidad mr
blackman
and he
swear to god i was the thing
i sure know what's his name
mr black man no no we didn't that wasn't
like
that was his real name
and he would always make us memorize
parts of julius caesar that's stupid
that's why he would always repeat things
twice you'd always be like you better
know that caesar
backwards
then he always had this at the end and
he would repeat it he would go slower
you're better
know
that
caesar
backwards
every time i see my friends from high
school they're like yo do the do mr
blackman
well you have to appreciate if anybody
didn't know who what mr blackman was
they just hear they do the black man
this is the racist on the metro
do the black man that should be the name
of this episode do the black man pause
all right
think about that
let's go all right i'm gonna get
skewered for that
uh
top
five answers are on the board name
halloween costumes that are professions
number one answer nurse doctor what's up
nurse
um
come on you got this easy
yeah
soldier
soldier is not on the board
police man police officers number two
firefighter firefighter is number three
because i know all the hoes
uh
you know all those people all the whole
you know you're all the hosts all the
hosts yeah the firemen yeah yeah yeah
anytime a [ __ ] come in with a fireman
outfit but her tv is popping out yeah
hey we're not safe and we're not putting
this [ __ ] is burning and we're not
paying you not putting no fire out
as long as your crotch is not burning
you know what i mean
fire burning fire on the dance floor so
we said firemen
i don't know what the fourth one's going
to be i'm going to just go with a random
one and say male woman
male woman is not on the board
did you mean like a male
woman or a male woman
like a male man but a male woman oh okay
that's not the kind of mail that i'm
yeah someone delivering the package
because i thought
male 1 yeah that's like that's a good
transfer [ __ ] you need to get out of
that whole [ __ ] gender binary thing
oh my bad it's all good what's the next
answer the final two answers
construction
and worker
were you gonna guess it i thought you
were saying no no absolutely not an
astronaut yeah i wasn't gonna get so no
i'm good with that no i'm good yeah yeah
construction worker i can see that
astronaut i've never i've never seen an
astronaut they just bought a shirt
maybe this is sparta bomber jacket that
says nasa and he said i'm a national
construction worker i've definitely seen
though yeah yeah that one that's the one
we missed
surprisingly soldierless people
though i will i've seen soldier way more
than i've seen
astronaut yeah like soldier was pretty
cool this is trash yeah
boomers
all right after
[Music]
six rounds
556 abba at 359
preach at 168. can we make it now so
that when i make points it just
subtracts it from what preach makes
you do whatever you want i'm just hoping
i can get it out to zero when you do
that you're already ahead
i just want to see if we get you down to
zero i think it's way cooler for me to
be like 300 to zero than it is for me to
be like 500 to 200 you know what i'm
saying you got issues
all right next one
and jp coming in hot at 34.
all right top four answers are on the
board name an animal that is extinct
do you want first good preach dinosaurs
dinosaurs number one
it's technically not an animal and so
it's an animal
reptiles are animals okay you're right
what the [ __ ] if it's not an animal what
is it
uh you're right okay
i think you're gonna get all the points
here so go ahead next one
nah that's all i got
so this is going to be random i don't
know if this even qualifies uh
neanderthals
humans
not on the board but i think they're
already too no humans are not considered
animals
i see what you're doing there am i crazy
no you're not correct yes you're crazy
but not for that some of us
some of us are [ __ ] animals
there's a bunch of vegans out there like
no no he gets it
uh yeah dinosaur that's all i got
what else is extent out there
all right there's a common phrase i got
one go ahead
joey mammoth is number two wooly what
wooly mammoth oh yeah yeah cause i know
they're not dinosaurs but they're really
old yeah i watched ice age once yes
mammoth yeah
we got two more
mcgallathan
is that a shakespeare play
that's just a water dynasty he's a wider
dinosaur's more dynamic
okay
saber-tooth saber-toothed tiger is
number three
it's pretty good it's pretty weird
yeah i'm not gonna lie i don't know
i like the [ __ ] is gone
yeah man damn that's sad
[Music]
how long have you been gone
wild okay
but yeah uh we're we're done with this
one tell us the last one is there's a
common phrase dead is the dodo
yes
all right final round
the top
five answers are on the board name a
first date faux pas
you got it
uh not pink
we're getting your wallet i'll give you
that one it's a is a number five when
they say forget your wallet yeah yeah
yeah [ __ ] you're not paying i forgot my
wallet
uh another faux pas would be uh not
smelling good
uh not on the board that's totally fine
apparently what not smelling good
i feel like on the first date if you're
like not hygienic or not clean though
that's not happening yeah
but it's not happening yo what's that
smell yeah is that you yeah what is a
full partner first date in this day and
age i don't even know if that exists
not eating ass
i feel like this hates like
you don't eat trying to have sex or like
no most people [ __ ] on the first date
nowadays yeah
well you know don't you think the answer
is
a faux pas on the first date yeah
they're just being drunk
that's not that one no that's cool
not on the board [ __ ] i don't know
i definitely don't know [ __ ] what i know
think of a stereotype that pertains to
both of our cultures okay
dressing too [ __ ]
how does that relate to our culture
you come out of dangerous are too [ __ ]
people judge you hard right yeah
okay
jb you got something
this man's in a relationship because i'm
staying out of
trouble do they say about the both
middle eastern people and black people
that's very true
we talk loud
that is true but
um
okay well listen if i had to guess what
a faux pas on the first date would be um
showing up with another person
oh no being late being late is number
two
what do you say about us
what's another full point
races uh bringing your child
a child that's not a faux pas
that's not a full body you [ __ ] you
crazy
[ __ ] you crazy no you're a grown
ass man you bring your whole ass kid
you're like yeah i didn't find a
babysitter so yeah this is state hey
you don't mind paying for him too you
get to be you get to meet your stepmom
what the [ __ ] your son's like hey listen
i get it i get it i i don't
that's so crazy that's not even a faux
pas that's not a faux pas [ __ ] were you
walking
were you even walking if you don't know
why you said that because football is a
french and uh don't it's like
yeah step in yeah wrong step faux pas is
the translation of wrong step exactly
um yeah give us an answer
i'm not
that really felt like an order and i'm
not gonna
[Laughter]
it's a chance to make a comeback i i'm
not going to make a comeback with one i
mean listen you've already got most of
the answers so far
yeah but i mean to come back on within
yourself [ __ ]
believe in yourself ain't got nothing to
do with believing myself well i don't
know you got three 100 something songs
believe it or not there's a hundred
points in the whole never give up like
the haitian people
what
kupita
this [ __ ] said nothing but the kind of
sound of fire
i know what that is i heard that in a
dead press song once
yeah i was wondering what it was
you heard that in a dead press song i
believe that really yeah it's possible
that press sounds like so that people
see it
it means uh cut head and burn houses and
that's what the haitians were saying
when they went when they did the
revolutions
the whole song makes sense now yeah
um
on a first date
so don't be late is one of the answers
what was the other answer that i gave
uh you gave one and said your kids
no i think one of the first answers i
gave it was like you said forget you
said not
not paying for forgetting wallet was on
the board
uh looking at your phone
not on the board
not looking at your phone
you're close actually to one of them
i'm stretching it on if i'm stretching
not not looking at your date
no no no not paying attention
no
all right hey
i'm good what would be a faux pas you're
on a date what would like be
i mean smelling terrible would
definitely be it already said that
being too aggressive
think of a topic maybe of conversation
oh okay you want to talk about yourself
no
talk about religion politics
nope
money
all good this is all good with everybody
yeah what the [ __ ] is wrong with these
people all right what is it talking
about your ex
oh
and then talking non-stop is number four
wait you said talking about yourself
well talk non-stop yeah
you know what i'm gonna give it to you
yeah talking about yourself i feel like
yeah talking non-stop that's that's
because people who talk about themselves
they're not asking questions exactly
i lost that [ __ ]
what you mean you lost
the only losers are those who don't try
shut the [ __ ] up if you don't if you
don't get the [ __ ] out of here
[Music]
is that what we tell young men who try
to go out there and meet women
the only ones who fail those who don't
try i know some people cash health
some people want to cash out that's
stupid so where are we at the final
tally abba 403 points
preach 265 points
[Music]
yes cb jp with a hard 34. all right
yeah but you know jp said he's like 734
i had all the answers i just kept my
mouth shut
yeah you just keep raising your glasses
you get smarter that's how animating is
beautiful you know what cause he's got
eyes on the back of his hands yeah and
then if the camera shifts there's eyes
just there and another nose and another
brain being like we've almost got him
this [ __ ] the whole superhero
they don't say all right well that's it
for today's video hopefully you guys
enjoyed it uh yeah if you guys want to
catch the videos in full go up on the
patreon we have them there otherwise you
catch some clips over here
peace